the internet moves so fast they can  barely keep  up luckily our team comes through it  every day bringing us  jewels like this  oh my perfection lisey you are so good  oh my gosh that's really good  no no wait wait no way no way  [Applause]  hi i'm jose rolone and here are my three  kids and this  is how you stay productive and work from  home  feel free to massage my head too that  feels really nice helps me be super  productive  the the top is really nice i like it  when you like go in  thank you those are the sides  i would go over like right on the top  perfect hey drew this is emily  and this is how i pick up my kids from  school  there he is mama's angel boy  i've missed you and you and you and you  and you  my sweet pea angel boy get in the car  hey hannah come on down  kate and ryan in seventh grade  i hope  me  that was a real gem thanks internet  [Music]